so now some of the problems with with
the Marxist perspective seems to be that
victimhood the sense of enhanced
victimhood tends to produce an intense
sense of resentment and that's a very
bad idea because resentment is a very
toxic and violent emotion it's also very
ungrateful which is one of the things I
would really say about especially the
radical left student types especially at
Ivy League universities I mean it's
really quite a spectacle to see people
at places like Yale come out and agitate
as a consequence of the realization of
their own oppression when by any
reasonable standard current or
historical they're probably in the top
1/100 of a percent perhaps better than
that of all the people who have ever
lived anywhere ever
and so it really it's really it's really
quite staggering to me that the top
point zero zero one percent can express
their resentment about the top point
zero zero zero one percent in such
strident terms without noticing that
exactly the same claims of privilege
apply to them by as long as all you have
to do is transform the the bend in which
you're doing the the privilege
comparisons and that becomes immediately
self-evident and you know the fact that
as Americans let's say us North
Americans since I'm a Canadian that
we're staggeringly privileged compared
to the rest of the world is certainly a
consequence of the of what you might
describe is the arbitrariness of our
political borders and so but to forget
that when you're claiming a particular
brand of oppression for yourself seems
to me to be very ungrateful at the least
and certainly motivated let's say
politically because I think it justifies
your expression of hatred for those that
tiny fraction of people who are still
better off than you and also a degree of
historical ignorance that's absolutely
staggering in its magnitude and a
complete indictment of our education
system which should be indicted in every
possible way so now the Marxists might
claim to their benefit let's say
with this world view of class struggle
as being the primary driver of human
history and the well-off
socioeconomically because that's pretty
much the only way they defined well off
which is also something I take great
objection to because there's lots of
hierarchies in the world and there are
many important hierarchies and not all
of them can be reduced to socio-economic
status by any stretch of the imagination
imagine if you were 80 years old and you
had twenty million dollars you know you
might be perfectly happy to get rid of
all that money if you could be 18 again
so it's and you know one of the best
predictors of wealth in North America is
actually age because you know young
people haven't actually had much time to
make money whereas old people have had
quite a bit of time but the problem with
being old and rich is that you're still
old and that actually turns out to be
quite a serious problem because no
matter how rich you are you eventually
die and so the money is the money has a
very delimited if delimited effect with
regards to addressing the fundamental
problems of the suffering of life and we
know perfectly well from the empirical
perspective that once you have enough
money so that the bill collectors aren't
chasing you around essentially something
like the beginnings of a middle-class
existence or maybe the upper end of the
working class then additional money has
absolutely no bearing whatsoever on your
psychological well-being and that's
actually an indication of the
limitations of material comfort let's
say as a medication for the for the
suffering that's attendant on life it's
another thing that's very weak about the
Marxists and I think very interestingly
contradictory because they're very anti
capital in their structure but they're
so damn materialistic that it's
absolutely mind-boggling because the
Marxists are actually more convinced
that money is useful than most
capitalists as far as I can tell because
they believe that that money is in fact
the solution to all life's problems the
problem is is that just the right people
don't have the money and I think that's
a staggeringly naive perspective because
there's many there's many problems in
life that money just cannot solve and
there's a fair number of them that it
actually makes worse so anyways having
said all that you could also still
the case I used to work for a socialist
party in Canada when I was a kid about
six about time I was 14 till the time I
was about 17 before I figured out what
was wrong not so much with socialism per
se but with ideology per se and I
actually admired that the socialist
leaders that I had the fortune to be
introduced to because at that point they
were very much a voice for the
working-class a lot of union leaders and
people like that you know so they're
classic democratic socialists on the
labour end of the distribution and it's
absolutely necessary for labour and the
working class to have a political voice
something the Democrats might keep in
mind so and maybe they wouldn't lose
their elections quite so frequently now
I really think it's appalling you know
because it's necessary for the working
class to have a political voice so and
to have that transformed into identity
politics is a real catastrophe anyways I
think that the people that I met many of
them were genuinely concerned with the
problems of the working-class and you
know more power to them and so I think
there are people on the Left who who
genuinely are trying to make a
difference for people who could use a
fair shot at opportunity in life but at
the same time I noticed that a
tremendous number of the people
especially the lower end worker party
worker protestor types were more peevish
and resentful than good-hearted and kind
and it was about that time that I came
across George Orwell's famous critique
of left-wing thinking and in the UK when
in a book called road to Wigan pier
where he basically made the claim that
the Socialists that he knew especially
the middle class ones didn't give a damn
about the poor they just hated the rich
and that's I mean that is something
worth thinking about for a very long
period of time because hatred actually
turns out to be a very powerful
motivation you know and and if you think
about the sorts of things that happened
in the Soviet Union and all these places
that were supposed to be workers
paradises if you look at the outcome and
you had to infer whether it was goodness
of heart and kindheartedness and care
for the working man that produced the
genocides or outright bitter resentful
resentment and hatred it's a lot easier
to draw a causal
from the negative emotion to the outcome
them from the positive kind-hearted
benevolence to thou you just don't get
goo lags out of benevolence that's just
not how it works so I think the bloody
historical evidence is clear although I
have read the most convoluted
pathological pathetic twisted
rationalizations of what happens stay in
Stalinist Russia that you could possibly
manufacture it's as if a stack of
corpses that would reach halfway to the
moon isn't enough evidence for the
pathology of a certain form of belief so
well some people can't be convinced by
anyone's death but their own I suppose